we're back Hey look they supposed to be
here oh hey is anyone else here everyone
was supposed to be back by now how are
you being here Jay says Christmas Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas tree yeah you
too man and happy New Year to you guys
it's 2017 welcome to the Santa Nico
Channel yes every year the streamys
happen in every year the stream needs
give us an award just so happens we got
another visual effects award to the hard
blood sweat and tears that ran is put
into these videos thanks Ren thanks
streamys let's go put it over here on
the shelf
we don't dust them off that frequently
so every January we come back and dust
our awards yeah this one's looking a
little dirty
yeah dude much better look at that shine
you miss that's cool good isn't
it hold on
I don't know about you guys but I spent
a whole bunch of money and Christmas
gifts this year I got a really big
family so if it's cool you guys I look
for the gray immigration in this video
right really this just one first one
first one they get a curse from da you
all that season the giving season
beginning now guys cool is that
cool because this video is brought to
you by Lenovo in the fam - pro so Lenovo
reached out to us and asked if we would
be interested in making a video about
their phone the fab 2 pro what lenovo
does not know is that a fan actually
emailed us two months ago about this
phone saying they were developing a
filmmaking program for this phone using
tango now what does tango tango is this
piece of technology that Google has been
working on that's the phone track its
position in 3d space so this guy made a
piece of software that using that 3d
tracking would stabilize your video
better than anything else out there that
does artificial video stabilization so I
said yes please send us the phone
because I want to check out that program
and see how it works but before I do let
me let me show you guys what tango is I
don't think everybody quite gets this
whole I've only seen one demo of this so
far yeah and even that was pretty
impressive so on the back of this phone
it's a whole suite of sensors here
cameras and I think a depth sensor a
couple other things that are constantly
scanning the environment what's
basically doing real-time motion
tracking for example you can pull up
video and have things overlaid in your
video basically real-time visual effects
right now you like your pet deep best
pet way better than Hobie oh he likes it
alright so I've loaded up this program
called hollow which will let you take 3d
scan models that are actual like people
or objects in a room and place them in
the environment so this I think this
will show off the tracking better than
anything else a monkey over there
he's like forget about it
yeah really funny I bet he's playing
your song man actually working run free
pretty good actually I'm really
surprised oh he's getting taller he's
growing he's growing he's like Hodor now
there is just chillin hi this guy right
here
it's not good around guests Trekkies so
guy Wow my arms like what do you need
bad in zombie thing that is pretty
impressive oh nice enough messing around
hopefully you guys get the idea of how
tango works it gives you this whenever
we do visual effect shots we need to put
a fake element into a real shot enough
games
let's go apply this filmmaking let's go
test out that stabilization program so I
fired up the app it's called cinematic
you can check it out on the Google Play
Store if you happen to have a tango
enabled device at tab 2 Pro it actually
does a stabilization in real time so now
I'm recording in real time it shows me
the stabilization this is much more
stable that any sort of like gyroscope
based stabilizer like you get with
hyperlapse because it's getting an
actual 3d track of the environment and
stabilizing off of that so it's rock
solid it's like a Steadicam it's pretty
great spread especially in
dude that's like a Steadicam that's
total Steadicam status well a virtual
gimbal gal jealous Nick my steady shots
yeah yeah I'd be too it's like bad boys
to status right here
[Applause]
right
[Music]
getting real-time stabilization and
real-time motion tracking data and like
a depth mat out of your scene the story
of also gives you an ecliptic because
it's getting environment treaty it gives
you a 3d view
it also has baked up the field if you
wanted to ah yep that's so crazy
thanks Lenovo for sending us a fab 2 pro
if you guys are interested in learning
more about tango and the technology
inside of the cell phone awesome to
colleagues in the description below also
if you're interested in getting a cell
phone that pads tango technology built
into it the fabric you Pro is the first
phone on the market with that tech so
that's something at six a fancy go check
it out thanks for watching guys so if
you guys thought this was cool and you
want to see some more Lenovo fat to pro
videos just click on the end screen here
and you can see some more examples of
what this awesome technology can do
thanks for watching
[Music]